[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record and we talk about
whatever we want friend's like what the
[ __ ]
thank you that's what we didn't tell her
i did i said i was going to do an intro
really quick yeah but
she didn't know that we all say it
together i totally forgot i just saw
your eyes go what the [ __ ]
i missed out i forgot about that part
because this is wren's first time being
on
if you tv know red she works at barbell
like with barbell
yep and she does all of our ambassador
rep stuff she's our ambassador manager
so if you want free gear dm her she's
the one that
sent you free gear no no no what is an
ambassador
what is an ambassador uh a person that
reps the company the brand
or clothing equipment whatever somebody
that sponsored it sounds
like pretty much a sponsorship
ambassador just sounds way cooler
instead of saying hey you're sponsored
um
but now you're an ambassador with us
just sounds
really cool love it especially for a gym
if you work at old navy all the workers
there are all ambassadors too
ah please do not compare us to old navy
the whole brand i remember because i
used to work at uh republic
and they're like you guys you're right
yeah they're all gonna happen
yeah maybe right and they're like you
guys do not just like you guys are not
retail workers you guys are all
ambassadors to this company
so whenever you guys talk about like
your job title you're like yeah i'm an
ambassador to banana republic
that sounds better it does sound a lot
cooler oh genius yeah isn't that kind of
condescending like shut up genius
like i don't know when you say it like
that okay fine it is like that
yeah that's funny but yeah so i was
giving her a little heads up before we
started this video and i totally forgot
to tell her about that intro
all right so the most interesting thing
that i want to talk about is you guys
know that we're super into like bitcoin
and crypto whatever
and tiff found out your mom has four of
them
yeah so i asked my mom because remember
i talked about this all the time where
my mom
was like 120 grand at least yes and old
people don't really know about this kind
of [ __ ]
well she's not that old she's only 18
years older than me what is that and i'm
31 you do the math i don't know 49 49.
that's not that old that's kind of old
though but we got fans that are older
she's five years away from getting
specials at vegas oh really
yeah that's pretty true 55 plus
you get like four sunny-side up eggs
with a price of two dude
you're not a senior citizen at 55. you
can get specials right now though i can
get you guys you want to go to a strip
club i can get you a car
whoa [ __ ] wait a car you guys are old
get you a limo
yeah and when they get when you get
there though you have to pay but it's
free
until you get that's what they did to us
yeah they sure did
they sure did they [ __ ] dude that
sucked so bad
yeah so what about your mom i guess i
guess your mom is old to me
not by number but by status right she's
a grandma she's my mom
and a grandma yes she's a grandma a
literal grandma a little grandma i made
her a grandma really young
but anyway she was like a 30 year old
grandma she's like 36.
[ __ ] you said that she loves scams right
no she doesn't love scams you told me
that you're twisting my words so
a little context so my mom she's always
tended to be susceptible to scamp so she
loves scabs how did i just interpret
that she should love it
was she a herbalife ambassador uh no but
not far off or mary kay no she didn't do
that amway
no she sells some knives avon she never
sold things
she just buys things so she's the
scammed not the scammer tupperware
parties yeah something like that
something like that oh oh she was part
of some like interior design
one that that was like that like you
have to buy drapes off of me and then
you saw those drapes
like that yeah where it was like it was
like like it's like shaped like this
something like that but anyway my mom
has always gotten
susceptible to fall for these things so
then years ago
like a decade ago almost she was telling
me about bitcoin and she was like oh my
god mikhail you have to check this thing
out it's so cool
it's only a hundred dollars right now to
get one bitcoin
and like there's only a limited amount
like she knew so much about it
and i was like mom mija it's on the
blockchain
she literally was saying yeah it's on
the blockchain and like you know
you can't just the [ __ ] government
[ __ ] you know it's decentralized
currency
come on man it's the algorithm exactly
she was trying to school me on this you
know
it was literally in one year not the
other example what's amazing no matter
what you were doing back then it wasn't
worth not getting into bitcoin
like you're talking about like 2010
right around yeah
whatever you were doing i never even
heard of bitcoin back then though
exactly yeah so my mom was
the first person that i heard about
bitcoin so then she had
uh she had coinbase on her phone and she
was showing me literally like the price
of bitcoin
a hundred dollars she's like mika you
gotta get like at least ten like put
a thousand aside get at least ten she
gave you some good financial advice
oh and i didn't listen but yeah so she
would have been 30 grand
300 i don't know how many she ended up
buying herself because it was
more than the four that she now has but
she told me that she now has four
but the thing is it's stuck in that cell
phone
that she had at the time because back
then she said that
the bitcoin was attached to that device
so if she doesn't have the device
no she can't if it's on coinbase she can
just log in no she said i asked her too
i was like mom can't you just log into
your account she's like no
back then it wasn't like that it's not
in the phone oh people are the worst
yeah she just she just made up her mind
that it's in the phone it's not in the
phone
that's what i told her and she was like
no it's attached to the device because
she looked into it because i told her i
was like mom do you know how much money
that's worth right now she's like i know
me
i'm trying to get it she think it's in
the phone like if she
unscrews the phone there's four bitcoins
laying there
so she can't charge this phone she can't
get this no no so then this phone she
gave to my brother
and my brother i was like facetiming
them talking about this and then my
brother's like
oh my god that's where the bitcoin is
mom you should have told me this i'm
going to go
to my room right now and go look for
that phone so that was the last of the
conversation i don't know if you found
the phone 100 g's he didn't turn his
room upside down for a hundred g's
people driving [ __ ] crazy they're not
these people they're not family no no
i'm saying
there's a lot of people like this who
think that their bitcoins
are on the phone or on some hard drive
or some [ __ ] yeah well she was saying
she drives me nuts linked to the phone
that she can't
access her account and i don't know
there's a cat who has um oh yeah we're
gonna talk about him oh yeah he has like
a thousand bitcoins stuck on a hard
drive or some [ __ ]
oh it drives me [ __ ] crazy it makes
me so sad there's actually multiple
stories
there's a lot there's people that commit
suicide right they're like oh my god
i have like ten million dollars [ __ ]
myself and then you guys jump off a
building no
i don't know i have to ask my brother i
don't know if he ever found the phone
but he says he has the phone
so we'll find out why isn't he like
doing whatever he can to get to get get
the bitcoins off of it i
well that's she checked her coinbase
account there's no there's no coins in
there
uh he didn't call customers too right
now oh their customer service is the
worst it's horrible it's the worst
like if you are out of your account
you're [ __ ] like oh they just don't
help you they don't help
even if you have millions you have to
bug them you have to really bug them
real [ __ ] them wouldn't you bug them if
you have a hundred
you should okay yeah but is casey
bugging
him uh i think he got his account
because i sent him
he started a new account oh okay yeah
but the other account
i helped him set up a new account but
then he's still frozen out of his own
exactly oh my gosh it's not stuck in the
computer
unscrew the computer get out
damn that's crazy they should start a
business of helping people get to their
crypto
oh yeah no they were saying they have
those they have some of those like some
of the businesses as long as you have
like part of the
like info that you need they uh they
help each other get the rest
so you need some of it though isn't uh
like blockchain though like
i remember when you're explaining to me
like if one transaction happens right
it's almost if everyone
everyone will be notified of it at the
same time yeah it's called consensus
so if if that's the case um like what
does
like let's say her mommy to present like
her ip address at the time of the
purchase
so she needs their she needs her key her
private key to
like she set one up i i don't know
because it's probably on the she must
have it on some kind of a wall
of one of those wallets where you have a
private key that's the only thing that
makes sense to me
if it's not on her coinbase account how
did the guys at
connect do it because they were selling
to normies
well that was a pyramid scheme yeah
that's what i'm thinking what if it was
oh no because what they would do
is they would tell people that they're
they're buying bitcoin
but you're just buying into their
company which has shares of bitcoin
oh no i remember when that whole thing
came out because immediately i
all this time every time i thought about
bitcoin i thought about oh my mom's in
some pyramids game thing again
like that was the link for me in my head
so then when we found out about that
big connect i immediately sent my mom
the article i was like were you involved
with this she's like no
i was with big connection
not big connects yeah yeah because there
it might be things like that that's
happening i don't know
it's kind of it's kind of weird you hear
recently about the guy who
he i think he has his information stored
on something where
he has like 10 attempts to try and he's
done that's the one that we're going to
talk about later
oh that's crazy he has a thousand on
there that's the guy i was talking about
that's crazy a thousand
damn that's [ __ ] crazy man i would
just give it up
dude when he set that [ __ ] up too he's
like i'm protected
i was having this conversation with my
buddy about like uh
risking a lot of money and then he was
telling me how like
a lot of people right they don't risk
because they can't deal with the
aftermath of losing it the emotional
part
the psychological part is what is
um i guess more um like hard to deal
with
stocks i i can't deal with the emotional
rollercoaster can't handle how it always
goes up
yeah you handle that yeah
that's hard it literally always goes up
in a line like this
yeah that's too much to deal with what
do you do with all that money
i don't know even just thinking about
like [ __ ] 10 years ago
i could have just you know
damn now it's only going down and then
like so i can't even deal with
the fact that i didn't even buy it
imagine being in it no
well a lot of a lot of people deal with
that so they don't risk
a lot and then i was like oh [ __ ] i
don't know if i have that
no [ __ ] no so that's why um it's
dangerous
to to play with these kind of games
we're degenerates dude that's why yeah
we're [ __ ] smart that you know who
you are so you just play accordingly
because like the number one rule is
supposed to be you play only with what
you're willing to lose
yep so the people that are until you
lose it and you go
wait a minute but i think it's not even
that right like the guys that are
flipping out
are the are the guys that are like hey i
bought [ __ ] bitcoin for like a
thousand bucks and i forgot about it 20
years ago or whatever [ __ ]
and then now they find out that it's
like 10 million or whatever right
and then they're like oh my god and then
they kill themselves and it's like that
was never your money
it's just it's just your mind yeah but
people get overly invested though
too that's the other thing like people
even on uh
when you see the fluctuations they freak
out yeah so what that means is like you
don't technically
actualize your wins and losses until you
sell
right so let's say you bought something
for like a thousand bucks right
and then you just see the number going
down to 800 you didn't actually lose 200
it's just it's until you sell it then
you
then you realize it the fun is when you
take out
years ago took out my initial investment
so i've just been riding on profits the
whole time so no matter what it's not
really real to me
it's all just kind of funny money yeah
so it makes it all easier
because i took out my initial investment
mine's the opposite
all of mine is the initial investment so
it's not funny money like yours
well that's because you guys are psychos
dude you guys are [ __ ] degenerate
psychos
i'm down i could have bought a house in
cash dude
you guys are [ __ ] legend forever dude
are cryptos uh comparable to gambling
oh absolutely the way we do it
absolutely the way i do it
to be like stocks i guess right but like
way more fluctuating it's
crazier because stuff no matter what are
going on
the way that it works i would compare it
to yeah yeah the concept of it yeah i
think that
um depending on the person how you
approach it can be gambling
and how you approach it can be investing
so
for example stocks right like you can
you can be
crazy and just like invest all your
money into this new company
that no one's ever heard of or you could
go hey this is kind of
this is more sound like amazon or
whatever but it's still risky compared
to
like doing a bond or something but
stocks like you
can make it a job like a day trader but
can you
make gambling a job yeah you can there
are no professional gamblers
no no i know like poker and all of that
but i'm like thinking
there's professional day trader for
crypto yeah and they make
[ __ ] tons i think the difference is like
one is more
just emotional and crazy and then the
other one is calculated
and logical uh approaching everything
like i know professional gamblers too
and it's hella boring like they're just
all about math and they stick to the
math that's all they do
and then for me i'm like i rather just
throw my money and close my eyes and
hope that it turns into
like 10 times yep and then i lose it all
and i go woohoo
and i'm like damn that is how you gamble
in vegas i've seen that yeah oh yeah
but that's gambling right you just it's
it's there's no thought behind it it's
just stupid
well that's why i like crypto though
because i choose specific projects that
i'm like okay i like this one
because it does this and all that kind
of [ __ ] i don't consider what we do
investing though
not one bit well it definitely doesn't
feel like investing we're
running around the room it doesn't feel
like we're like some knowledgeable
people or whatever in the crypto sphere
we're [ __ ] running around the room
sending each other ric flair memes
definitely not the closest thing that i
have to like owning something long time
ago
and now it being valuable or basketball
cards
so i know garyvee was talking about how
you just sold like a basketball court or
something for like 30 g's
pokemon cards are coming back and i i
actually have a [ __ ] ton
yeah when i was a kid what i think i
should go get them appraised
where do you have it they're on my mom's
house you found a whole bunch of them
too and we went to the
the when we bought furniture remember i
actually bought those
because so i went with casey and tiff to
buy furniture when we're building the
downtown office and they're trying to
buy like vintage stuff
and then there was a box of just like
jordan
scotty pippen like mint condition cards
and i was like how much are these cards
and the whole stack was like five
dollars what did you got them all
yeah i was like of course i'm like all
right here's five bucks so i have a
whole
stack of those two plus the ones i had
as a kid
wow well so you didn't lose it i don't
yeah i've never lost it okay yeah i've
never lost it
wow well my mom's a huge hoarder as
everyone knows and she
cannot find our first edition pokemon
cards out of all the things that she
hoards
she can't find them how much are those
words you guys dude you guys could
probably
like find it and then sell it right yeah
well that that would be the hope if we
could ever get through the mountain of
trash
damn yeah i bet you if your mom sold
everything on ebay you guys would
probably have over a million dollars
worth of junk in that house
true i guarantee but such a pain in the
ass i would pay a million dollars not to
do it
i'm sorry how big pokemon is coming back
i like i keep seeing it all the time on
my instagram of like different people
opening up packs
really yeah it's like it's a huge
nostalgia play
everyone loves like the they like to
remember their childhood by having the
old cards and opening them and [ __ ] do
you think bb babies will ever come back
oh [ __ ] i remember those guys dude some
of them sold like millions or whatever
too right yeah
like the princess diana one the the
purple bear one did you collect them
well kinda so my aunt was the one that
was like
super into it and so she would always
give all all of like the cousins it
wasn't scammy enough for your mom
yeah well my mom kind of got into it a
little bit but um but yeah so
so then like i did have like a huge ass
collection of beanie babies but it was
mainly because my aunt kept gifting them
and then my mom would buy some too
and yeah i don't even i don't even know
if my aunt still has them
where's your mom like don't touch that
that's an investment
[Laughter]
some of them there's people out there
who have mountains of beanie babies they
can't [ __ ] sell them though yeah
because it was a huge bubble
talk about an actual bubble right yeah
yeah yeah like that's a bubble that
never
got reinflated but some people are out
there i've been hoarding for the day
like the day it's coming back like i got
ten thousand beanie babies really she's
gonna take
maybe in 50 years right the day that
they die
they start to skyrocket on ebay no but
yeah i was actually looking because i
had that princess diana beanie baby
oh you hadn't had that specific one oh
my god i had that exact
one but your brother has it now
in a closet he can't find it no it is
yours and there's bitcoin in his stomach
no so i only kept two beanie babies out
of my whole collection it was like the
this like bigger red one with the
mexican flag on it and that princess
diana one
and i still have the red one and i
couldn't find the princess anna one
after
i read an article how that bear was
worth like
i don't know how much money a lot of
money for to make me freak out and try
to find it
and i couldn't [ __ ] find it but also
it had to be the specific
one that was sold in the uk during like
around that time so i didn't have that
specific one but damn
oh yeah your mom probably sold it bought
the bitcoin
now it's gone damn it
my bear but yeah i don't know
all these collection stuff is just so i
think the next thing that's
well it's kind of already popping off
and it's been a thing but i think it's
like
vintage wear because the shoe thing well
you know shoes really popped off and
then
i think this is the next thing to go
because it's pretty damn popular right
right
right
right
right
right
right
by vintage where you mean just like like
going thrifting and then selling that
stuff
uh so there's the vintage market and
then there's thrifting so like thrifting
is like
basically a lot of non-profit
organizations and then you find
good stuff but vintage shops are curated
uh kind of boutique old-school stuff out
of thrift store stuff
yeah so it's like going to garage sales
and then finding dope pokemon cards and
then you're going
oh wow i'm gonna sell this at my store
so then if you go to a vintage shop
like it's typically like around a
certain style or culture
so you can have like street wear that
sells like vintage t-shirts or whatever
or you can have like
like maybe like a biker style where it's
like a bunch of like
old-school leather stuff or band
t-shirts and
some of them are like special like oh
they were at this concert it's the last
concert and then these t-shirts go for
like 250 bucks or whatever i know people
who used to do that
but like with goodwill because you could
go to like the goodwill warehouse
and rather than paying like 12 bucks for
a shirt or whatever you pay by the pound
yeah so they can drift through all the
bins and stuff like that and you pay
like
a few bucks for a pound of like
thousands of dollars worth of like
expensive clothes and you can find that
like diamond in the rough
yeah you have to like know what you're
looking for if i was there i'd be like
everything just smells bad
you gotta take that stars guy that one
knows everything
yeah do you know what colors too
everything yeah [ __ ] sword
gumball machines clothes it's because
it's heavily produced so he's got
somebody next to him like hey just
before this here's what it does
he always has an expert friend yeah i
got his money i'm like
how many friends do you have dude your
parties must be crazy
you